Jean-Louis bourlange vous restez avec
nous vous êtes notre grand témoin ce
soir on va évoquer avec vous très honoré
la situation internationale car vous
présidez je le rappelle la commission
des affaires étrangères à l'Assemblée
mais d'abord votre portrait qui est
signé Marco
pommier si on vous invite Jean-Louis
bourlange c'est pour avoir votre regard
sur cet ordre mondial bouleversé alors
que l'Occident paraît plus que jamais
impuissant face au conflits multiples
terrorisme en Europe invasion de
l'Ukraine offensive de l'Azerbaïjan dans
le haut cararabach et bien sûr cette
guerre entre Israël et le Hamas
situation humanitaire catastrophique à
Gaza bombardé sans relâche par l'armée
israélienne la réplique des massacres du
7 octobre une guerre qui enflamme les
débats de l'assemblé vous vous
abandonnez à la pente inarrêtable de la
guerre on les filles et au Mélan votre
position elle a marqué les esprits
Jean-Louis bourlange on vous a vu
affaibl ouff sur une idée excusez-moi je
me sens pas très bien mais vous êtes
allé au bout de votre discours
condamnant l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
tout en critiquant la politique de
Benyamin netanah le gouvernement
israélien s'est estimé libre d'engager
sans risque une relance rampante mais
brutale et déterminée de sa politique de
colonisation en 6 Jordanie discours
applaudi sur les bans de la gauche moins
apprécié dans votre propre
camp du grand public Jean-Louis
bourlange votre réputation n'est plus à
faire à l'Assemblée 2017 vous sortez de
votre retraite politique anticipé pour
soutenir le candidat Macron député MoDem
depuis 6 ans président de la
prestigieuse commission des affaires
étrangères de vous nous retenons aussi
l'énarque passionné d'Europe entré au
Parlement de Strasbourg en
1989 sur la liste d'une certaine Simone
veille le fait que ce soit elle qui
choisissent l'Europe c'était infiniment
porteur ça voulait dire que tout le
monde devait choisir l'Europe l'Europe
qui affronte aujourd'hui le retour de la
guerre plus de 600 jours d'offensive
militaire ruses en Ukraine et un conflit
qui s'enlise mais éclipsé aujourd'hui
par le Proche-Orient qui s'embrase des
crises articulées les unes aux autres
dites-vous derrière le Hamas il y a le
hzbollah derrière le hbollah il y a
l'Iran derrière l'Iran il y a la Russie
et la Chine alors Jean-Louis bourlange
don ce monde instable intranquille que
peut faire la France pour éviter
l'embrasement général et je vais vous
poser cette question évidemment jean-l
bourlange mais d'abord cette dernière
information qui nous est donnée par le
qu d'orsé ce soir deux enfants français
ont été tués dans le nord de la bande de
Gaza leur mère a été blessée Jean-Louis
bourlange la France a longtemps porté
une voix d'équilibre qui était entendu
et respecté par les deux camps au Proche
Orient aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
la France redécouvre couvre un peu ce
dossier du Proche Orient après avoir
laissé le laissé aux mains des des
États-Unis euh je reformule un peu la
question de Marco Pomier que doit faire
la France pour peser à nouveau dans les
dans la région pour uvrer à une
désescalade écez je crois que ce n'est
pas simplement la France c'est l'Europe
qui s'était mobilisé très fortement sur
la la France seule ne peut ne peut ne
peut pas j'ai pas dit ça j'ai pas dit se
bien sûr que la France ne peut pas c'est
évident on va pas intervenir
militairement la bande de Gaza dire à
l'État d'Israël faut faire si c et ça
s'il ne veut pas le faire c'est c'est
une évidence nous sommes une puissance
moyenne nous sommes dotés d'armes
puissante nous pouvons nous défendre
nous pouvons agir nous pouvons aider
mais nous ne pouvons pas décider à la
place des autres mais l'Europe j'y
reviens avait des avait vraiment pris
une position la déclaration de Venise
qui est de quoi de 81 c'est très très
vieux tout ça on avait pris position
clairement pour une solution à deux
états pourquoi l'avait-on fait parce que
que c'est comme ça qu'on avait fait
l'Europe on avait dit les Allemands les
Français ça avait été assez assez chaud
he pendant plus d'un siècle et on avait
dit si on veut s'en tirer si on veut
vivre en paix tranquillement il faut
qu'on respecte l'autre il faut que les
intérêts légitimes de chacun des
protagonistes soient reconnus et ce que
nous avons dit avec les deux états
c'était je je discutais avec un un
ancien ambassadeur qui me rappelait un
déjeuner qu'il avait eu avec Rabine
là-dessus et Rabine lui disait nous av
av une une un court moment où nous
pouvons réaliser cela et ce qui s'est
passé et la France était évidemment la
France était très porteuse de cela elle
avait embrayé l'Europe et puis ce qui
s'est passé c'est que les États-Unis
n'ont pas vraiment suivi ils ont suivi à
un moment et puis après l'assassinat de
Rabine l'assassinat de Sadat on est
passé vers quelque chose de très
différent et qui de qu'on dont on voit
aujourd'hui les conséquences négatives
parce que effectivement le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que la sécurité profonde
d'Israël ne sera pas durablement assurée
si il n'y a
pas un environnement pacifié autour vous
parliz d'un d'un état vulnérable dans
votre discours la semaine dernière à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a 15 il y a
15 millions de Juifs dans le monde 6
millions à peu près en Israël et il y a
15illard 500 millions de musulmans ça
pose un problème quand même vous avez
vous avez eu ces mots la violence
barbare du Hamas est sans excuses mais
pas sans C dans votre discours vous avez
clairement condamné les actes
terroristes à viser génocidaire du Hamas
mais vous avez également condamné la
politique de colonisation du
gouvernement israélien de de Benyamin
netaniahou c'est un discours que
certains ont qualifié de de chirakien
personne ne l'a qualifié de macroniste
pourquoi selon vous écoutez je ne sais
pas c'est parce que peut-être Emmanuel
Macron ne sétait pas encore exprimé
quand j'ai quand j'ai prononcé mon quand
j'ai prononcer ce ce
discours c'est
c'est c'est c'est vrai que ça s'inscrit
dans la grande tradition
française Gén celle le Chirac et alors
Emmanuel Macron non regardez ce que le
voyage Emmanuel Macron a été dans le bon
sens à part ce que je considère comme
une expression vraiment pas très
heureuse qui est l'appel à la la
coalition internationale à la coalition
ça je crois que c'est pas du tout la
phrase qu'il fallait le mot qu'il
fallait employer mais en revanche Macron
par rapport à pas mal le chefs d'État de
gouvernement a fait le travail avec tout
le monde il est il a parlé au aux
autorités israéliennes bien entendu il a
parlé aux autorités à l'Autorité
palestinienne il a été voir le roi
Abdallah Jordani il a été voir le
maréchal Sissi donc tous les
protagonistes et il a rappelé la notre
notre volonté de contribuer à aux deux
états vous l'avez entendu condamner la
la colonisation de laass-jordanie oui il
a il a dit des choses qui étai condamné
oui il a dit des choses qui étaient
assez nettes à divers moments mais le le
problème le problème n'est pas là si je
puis me dire le problème c'est que nous
sommes engagés actuellement au
Moyen-Orient dans un processus
absolument terrifiant moi je ne sais pas
je ne vois pas exactement ce que je
comprends très très bien le droit à la
légitime défense d'Israël les violences
qui ont
été subies par le peuple par le peuple
israélien j'ai parlé de crime de guerre
de crime contre l'humanité de terrorisme
tout ça est totalement vrai mais
aujourd'hui quel est le but politique de
cette de de ces bombardements
systématiques en à Gaza comment le le
Premier ministre israélien envisage-t-il
de trouver une sortie politique on a 2
300000 personnes dans la bande de Gaza
qu'est-ce qu'on quel est le type de
relation qui va s'établir entre Israël
et ces 2300000 et en même temps en en
sjordanie je suis inquiet parce que je
vois que l'idée est de confier aux
colons qui sont vraiment juges et partis
une sorte de de de les transformer en
une sorte de garde nationale et ça ça
veut dire que la partie va être très
dure pour les Palestiniens qui vont être
victime de d'expropriation voire de de
de de de mise à mort ce qui s'est passé
au cours des deux dernières années n'est
pas au des dernières années n'est pas
brillant donc je crois qu'Israël doit
revenir absolument à sa logique qui
était celle de Shimon PES celle d'izarac
Rabine de dire nous n'aurons la paix que
si nous offrons à nos voisins un un un
avenir qui correspond à ce dont ce à
quoi ils ont droit c'est très difficile
et je crois que l'Europe et l'Europe me
paraît très divisé très incapable d'agir
moi je suis un Européen convaincu mais
je ne suis pas un Européen heureux
voyez-vous parce que je trouve que
l'Europe n'en fait pas assez je crois
que nous devons peser pour cette
solution qui est la seule solution qui
permettra à Israël de vivre durablement
en sécurité et en paix dans dans votre
discours toujours j'y reviens vous avez
eu une autre phrase vous vous expliquer
que on l'a entendu d'ailleurs he dans le
sujet de Marco Pomier derrière le
hzbollah derrière le Hamas il y a le
hzbollah derrière le Hezbollah il y a
l'Iran derrière l'Iran il y a la Russie
il y a la Chine est-ce que cette donnée
là aujourd'hui elle est suffisamment
prise en compte et qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire face à ça pour éviter cette oui ce
que j'ai voulu dire simplement c'était
un extrait mais ce que j'ai voulu dire
simplement c'est qu'il y avait un risque
d'escalade que si le Hamas est trop
massacré le hzbollah va intervenir si le
hzbolla est massacré l'Iran peut
intervenir et cetera il y a une un
risque de ce que kusvitaelle l'ascension
aux extrêmes bon c'est très réel je
crois qu'il y a des puissances
modératrices d'abord nous mais nous ne
sommes pas très puissants surtout les
États-Unis les
États-Unis je crois font une pression
extrêmement forte sur dans l'ensemble de
la zone notamment sur le Premier
ministre israélien pour qu'il en fasse
pas trop trop pour l'instant c'est pas
c'est pas écouté mais notamment je pense
que les Américains seraient très très
hostiles à des attaques puisqueà un
moment monsieur netanahou a dit qu'il
voulait aplatir le Liban à des attaques
sur le Liban puis il y a le problème de
l'Iran l'Iran c'est un état très assez
assez machiavellique c'est moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est intelligents et là il
me semble que c'est eux qui manipulent
par exemple c'est eux qui empêchent
alors que les gens du hzbollah voudrait
intervenir je pense que c'est eux qui
empêch le chef du hzbollah de déclencher
la guerre et c'est eux qui en à mon avis
au Yémen arme les outils en leur disant
là on fait un peu une attaque contre
Israël mais c'est relativement limité
parce qu'il me semble que les Iraniens
n'ont pas intérêt à à ce qu'il y ait une
escalade fondamental aujourd'hui mais
vous voyez à quel point ça à quel point
ce système est terriblement dangereux
nous avons une logique d'escalade d'un
côté et nous avons des états les
États-Unis le le l'Iran qui pour des
raisons totalement différentes l'amour
de la paix je crois pour les et de la
stabilité pour les États-Unis et la
protection de l'Iran qui ne veut pas
s'exposer à à à des catastrophes agit
mais je je trouve qu'il y a là un très
grand danger mais le principal danger
c'est que va-ton V faire en Palestine
des Palestiniens quand cette horrible
guerre sera terminée je je voudrais vous
faire réagir à une image qui a marqué
l'actualité aujourd'hui en France ce
sont ces étoiles de David qui ont été
taguées sur de nombreuses façades
d'immeubles à Paris dans plusieurs
villes de la de la région parisienne on
craignait l'importation du conflit
israélo-palestinien en France est-ce
qu'on a pas d'ors et déjà dépasser ce
stade quand on voit ces ces tagues
antisémite moi je suis je je crois que
c'est tragiquement logique que d'avoir
un développement de de la tension entre
les Arabes et et et les Juifs ce qui
s'est passé nous avons quand même en
France à peu près 5 ou 6 millions de
musulmans et et nous avons combien
400000 Juifs donc je comprends vraiment
très très bien que les Juifs se sentent
en situation de très grande
vulnérabilité on a des tas de
témoignages ils veulent pas plus mettre
la kipa ils veulent pas ils sont
extrêmement prudents ils ne se ils ne
s'affichent pas et cetera ils ont le
sentiment tout à fait légitime que ça
recommence h que ça recommence alors je
précise évidemment que pour l'instant on
a aucune idée de qui est
derrière ces inscriptions sur les sur
les façades d'immeubl mais ça traduit
clairement une montée de
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme est très
très précisément un antisémitisme arabe
en réalité c'est c'est c'est pas du tout
l'antisémitisme traditionnel de la
bourgeoisie française que nous avons
connu et qui n'est pas à l'honneur de
cette bourgeoisie euh dans les années 30
par exemple mais ou 40 c'est c'est autre
chose mais moi je je crois que euh le la
le le problème que ce qu'a montré ce ce
ce ce que montre cette crise c'est la
vulnérabilité du peuple juif et ça c'est
quand même terrible nous ne pouvons pas
accepter ça nous ne pouvons pas accepter
que après ce qui s'est passé entre 40 et
45 euh nous ne pouvons pas accepter que
c'est les Juifs soient à nouveau dans
une situation euh terrible mais la vraie
réponse c'est le contraire de ce que
fait le premier ministre israélien pas
seulement depuis 15 jours depuis euh
depuis une dizaines d'années il a
vraiment fait déraper la politique
israélienne dans dans une direction qui
à mon avis la conduit à l'impasse et là
je crois qu'il faut vraiment euh que la
communauté internationale se ressaisisse
et et c'est et que le peuple israélien
parce que il y a aussi les otages euh
les otages les gens veulent euh on va en
parler avec avecam va dans dans un
instant je voulais quand même d'un mot
vous entendre sur le rôle de la Chine et
de la Russie aujourd'hui dans ce
désordre mondial croissant on a
l'impression que beaucoup d'États du Sud
se rangent systématiquement derrière la
Chine et la Russie aujourd'hui qui sont
des régimes autoritaires que l'Occident
a un effet repoussoir que les
démocraties occidentales ne sont plus un
modèle pour le sud aujourd'hui que doit
faire l'Europe face à ça est-ce qu'elle
doit intégrer cette donne et adapter un
peu ses alliances stratégiques oou
est-ce qu'elle doit chercher à à contre
ce mouvement qui est engagé moi je ne
crois pas à la notion de Sud global je
crois qu'il y a effectivement des
dictatures tyranniques très forte la
Russie la Chine mais vous avez une très
grande démocratie comme l'Inde c'est une
démocratie imparfaite mais c'est une
démocratie qui est totalement étrangère
à ce à à ce phénomène vous avez un pays
comme le Brésil qui avait les premières
déclarations du du président loua
n'était pas très heureuse sur l'Ukraine
mais depuis il a fait mieux il a déposé
une résolution que nous Français nous
avons voté qui est une résolution très
équilibrée je crois que le modèle mais
c'est vrai que le modèle démocratique
euh a du plond dans l'ail actuellement y
compris chez nous y compris en y compris
en Europe euh je me réjouis quand même
au milieu de tout ça de voir que les
Polonais ont voté dans un sens qui euh
permet d'en faire à nouveau des
partenaires extrêmement actifs et
positifs dans l'Union européenne on en a
bien besoin donc vous êtes un pessimiste
actif comme vous définissez mais vous
vous réjouissez quand il y a quand même
des bonnes nouvelles dans dans cette
situation internationale Merci à VOUS
Jean-Louis bourlange